[Music]
let's track this from the beginning
[Music]
starke something pure
[Music]
something exciting
[Music]
then
[Music]
he was significant
[Music]
told you okay so far do I get I'm
feeling it
yeah
[Music]
why stop there
this is
this is the path I started us on
[Music]
I'll very strength
invites challenged
[Music]
[Applause]
insights comfort
[Music]
Brie's catastrophe
the thing isn't beautiful because it
lasts
[Applause]
[Music]
what a sweet-ass run it's been
EPIK forces of darkness mi
[Music]
[Applause]
universe
[Music]
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
it is finally here
the complete box set of all 23 films
that created and made the MCU over the
past 11 years since the start of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe now officially
titled and known as the infinity saga
this box set has been teased a lot and
it will include every single film that
exists in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
this box set will include every single
movie that exists in the MCU from phase
1 to the end of phase 3 from Iron Man to
avengers endgame and spider-man far from
home so if you were wondering what you
were going to do until the release of
phase 4 in 2020 this is your answer and
although we do not have an official
release date for the box set it should
be soon as we now have the trailer so it
shouldn't be long and of course you all
know as soon as it comes out I'll start
a new giveaway giving away one of these
box sets also I'm still giving away an
xbox one or a ps4 I gave away one at
500,000 subscribers now I'm giving away
another one at 550 thousand subscribers
so if you want to enter for your chance
to win all you have to do is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and comment below with your favorite
superhero or villain you can also click
the link in the description down below
for your chance to win a Nintendo switch
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof